An IPv4 address is actually a 32-bit or
4 octet value,
which we usually write as a dotted quad.
But writing an IP address
as four decimal numbers is
just a convention to
make it easier to read.
When it's used between computers it's
just a 32 bit long string of bits.
However, not all of the possible 32 bit
values are used for real addresses.
Some of them are reserved for
special protocols.
internal private networks.
Some of them are for
testing or for documentation.
In fact, just over one-eighth
of all possible IPv4 addresses,
are set aside for something other
than addressing public hosts.
But as you'll see, even if we did use
all 32 bit addresses to represent public
hosts that still wouldn't
really be enough.